This equation will be a parabola that opens downward. Great work if you got it.
We know it's a parabola since we have an x squared term, but just a y term. We
don't have y squared. Because we don't have both x squared and y squared, we
know our shape will be a parabola. To figure out which direction the parabola
opens, we need to solve for y. So, first I'll subtract 27 from both sides of
the equation. We subtract 27 here and here, to get this new equation. Now we
want to divide every term by negative 4 to get y by itself. So, dividing this
by negative 4, we get y. Dividing this by negative 4, we get positive 27
divided by 4 and dividing this by negative 4 we get negative three fourths x
squared. So since this equation is of the form y equals, we know that it's
going to open up, or it's going to open down. Since the x squared term has a
negative coefficient, our parabola opens downward. And, just to show you, this
equation is the one I have shown graphed, this equation is still the same. And
this one is identical as well. All three equations represent the same parabola
that opens down.